now the window of opportunity to be
climate change is rapidly closing
extreme weather events will only get
worse unless the world acts now to
secure a livable future for all the
stock predictions are outlined in a un
report that's expected to shape climate
policy in the years to come our
environment editor Nick Clark explains
in every country on every continent the
climate emergency is taking hold this is
Malawi hundreds dead hundreds of
thousands displaced the cause a
record-breaking Cyclone on the other
side of the world in Argentina endless
brutal heat compounding a drought with
Farmers facing losses estimated at 14
billion dollars
so now we have this latest Call to Arms
from the United Nations with what should
become the fundamental policy document
for shaping climate action it is the
distillation of years of work by
hundreds of scientists and these are the
key points in the past decade there have
been 15 times more deaths from droughts
floods and storms in more vulnerable
regions carbon emissions they need to
drop and rapidly in fact they need to
cut by almost half in just seven years
if global warming is to be limited to
one and a half degrees Celsius but a
rapid and far-reaching transition could
pull us back from the brink and to help
do that developed countries need to
stump up hundreds of billions of dollars
every year to vulnerable Nations
something they've so far failed to do
whether or not world leaders with that
is another matter it's not as if there
weren't warnings long ago this was
former NASA climate scientist James
Hansen way back in 1988 altogether
this evidence represents a very strong
case in my opinion that the greenhouse
effect has been detected and it is
changing our climate now
well as we now know the world didn't
listen 35 years on fossil fuel emissions
continue to increase along with colossal
profits for the oil Giants and
temperatures yes of course they're going
up too and now I'll say the experts once
and for all we need to act before that
window of opportunity slams shut
well let's now speak to Aditi Mukherjee
who's one of the authors of the ipcc
synthesis report she's live from
Interlaken where the report was released
earlier today thank you so much for
taking the time to speak to us this is
the culmination of work by hundreds of
scientists and experts including
yourself over eight years what makes
this report first of all more important
than any other report you've worked on
this report is extremely policy relevant
because it's it's providing a synthesis
of all the signs and the policy work
that has happened in the ipcc there is a
combination of the six reports that
happened in this cycle and it's actually
also telling us that while the the
reality is dire there is Reason for Hope
and that's because the report also lets
a whole lot of solution that can be and
should be implemented on an urgent basis
for us to avoid some of the urge some of
the crisis that was described let's talk
about some of those Solutions because
the report covers various aspects of
course of the climate crisis what is the
most immediate and drastic action that
countries need to make to prevent our
planet from overheating to dangerous
levels
most important is rapid deep rapid and
sustained reductions in emissions in
Greenhouse emissions and to be on the
track for 1.5 degree we have to have
emissions by the end of this decade
having said that what is also equally
needed is we already know that impacts
are happening and those who are facing
most of the impacts are some of the most
vulnerable the ones who have not emitted
so the one who have emitted the least
are the most vulnerable so adaptation
also is extremely important for helping
those vulnerable communities to adapt
better to the impacts but one of the
main findings of the report is that even
the even the way we adapt what we are
doing today will not be as effective at
a higher level of global warming so
mitigation reducing emissions is one of
the most important climate Solutions
followed by adaptation yeah the report
calls for the reduction of fossil fuel
emissions but as you know the world's
two biggest polluters China and the US
are continuing to to approve new fossil
fuel projects just last week the Biden
Administration approved an enormous oil
drilling project in Alaska they clearly
seems to be a lack of political will
the report underlines the importance of
so the report actually says that we have
the solutions which required our
political will governance policies and
institutions to actually Implement those
Solutions so it's as if we don't know
what we need to do we know we have the
solutions now what we need is that
political commitment and the will to go
ahead and do what's needed to secure a
livable future for us and for our
children what are the strategies then to
reduce fossil fuel emissions how do you
convince these governments that are
still doing it
I think the job of the ipcc synthesis
report we as scientists is to provide a
whole lot of options a menu of options
of how to go ahead then it actually
remains with the policy makers of how
they want to implement so as scientists
we have done our job in providing those
evidence and for to be taken up by the
policy makers so the report is I
understand a benchmark for governments
discussions on climate change and it
lays the groundwork for the next cop
meeting in Dubai at the end of this year
now last year's climate talks in Channel
shaik language calling for example for
an enter fossil fuels was struck from
the the final agreement after pressure
from several oil producing countries
you wonder how valid this process the
U.N climate process is when
recommendations that are made by
scientists like yourself are simply
ignored
again as I said a scientist our job is
to provide that evidence and the way it
is implemented leaves a lot to be
desired as you are very rightly pointing
out the other big part of the report
that we talked about this time and was
also talked about in the Sharma Shake is
around losses and damages so we for the
first time have evidence saying that
losses and damages is already happening
it's not as if we have to wait for the
future to see those losses and damages
and we talk about the importance of
Finance in the context of not only
overall climate Finance but also the
loss and damage fund that he's been set
up so there are those very important
findings from the report that we as
scientists hope would be taken up at
rates that's needed to tackle this huge
crisis okay thank you so much for taking
the time to speak to us Aditi Mukherjee
joining us live on the NewsHour